tous les cd de musique du dvd mots il ya
toutes sortes de formats roger chauveau
est l'un des tout premiers à s'être
impliquées dans le réseau de collecte
des cd usagés
chaque semaine il en récupère au bas mot
cinquantaine moi je fais de l'achat
vente était en bon état évidemment c'est
réutiliser revendus et puisqu'elle
mauvais état je leur explique voyez là
c'est illisible
donc ça va repartir à la destruction et
au lieu d'être une destruction of
l'ismans on préfère que ça soit recyclé
éviter l'enfouissement ou l'incinération
très polluant c'est le but du réseau de
collecte de ces galettes et ils sont
douze
comme ce magasin de vente de jeux vidéo
a participé à l'opération à orléans où
les mettez à la poubelle et maintenant
avec le système on peut les recycler via
l'association de boris
l'objectif c'est de parvenir à ce que
plus aucun cd dvd usage ils atterrissent
à la poubelle et ça ça nous permet donc
de préserver le pétrole avec lesquels
les cd ont été constitués parce que vous
pas le mettre dans le bac de bouteilles
en plastique
donc ce que le cd est constitué d'un
plastique qui est encore différent des
poux des autres plastiques qu'ils vont
dans les bacs
deux poubelles et donc il ne faut pas
mélanger ces plastiques ce plastique
il peut être transformé en éléments
d'ameublement et à l'avenir il pourrait
aussi servir d'isolant pour les
bâtiments c'est vraiment aussi de poser
un regard différent sur un support qui
est emblématique de notre époque et lui
permettre d'avoir une seconde vie
honorable et qui honore aussi les
générations futures
donc on leur en service si on évite
surtout ce à ce que cela retombe sur les
bras oui car malgré la tendance à une
consommation de biens dématérialisés 150
millions de cd dvd sont encore vendus en
france chaque année